Hi! My name is Lily Bond.
I'm the director of marketing here at 3Play Media.
And on a daily basis, I work with all types of marketing content.
So, I do blogs; I do white papers.
I do webinars all the time, go to a lot of conferences,...
...and then I manage our team and all of our marketing operations.
My name is Lanya Butler and I'm a full-stack engineer here at 3Play Media.
On a day-to-day basis, I might be fixing bugs,...
...I might be working on customer-facing products...
...or I might be working on internal tools.
My name is Donny Langham.
I'm an account manager at 3Play Media.
And account management is constantly asking customers...
...what could be better about our product,...
...what could help them out a little bit more,...
...and how we can make them successful.